fashion on owe me round end sound and worth
sense of an exception
in politics audi tt and killing the final of the games
hiv optical steadyshot from here spindle
he funds
[music]
chudaev i talking you svetlana tikhonovskaya
minds you have a comp cycle on all just wanna
go
bart was  game about you lord with mom
sims belarus
[music]
signal and in but [ __ ] photo on block sprays
nasty can i already proved it to the whole
world
i went out and was not afraid in this special
leadership position but i will change
belarus is a phone calls you plastic
for  to solve this long tunnel alexander
lukashenko
is not for his sexy svetulik now
accepting his imaginations dfmn a bunch of
musicians
scoundrel exactly here he is strewn in belarus
last svetlana herself after all that
you've been through do you think now
belarus is ready for a woman president
who i'll choose the future from  President in the
new fair elections, but I am more than
sure that yes, because yes, and my
colleagues and all the women of Belarus who
came out showed such and such  only such
strength of character that she killed the hands will
definitely remain no longer in doubt that a
woman can become a leader, the future
president of fear, somewhere that the
women proved a biopsy, I can already prove it to the
whole world, I went out and was not afraid that
we would not
be able to take a leadership position
tikhonovskaya
man collection but lukashenko
white 5 bars road king people color to
cancel
tikhonovskaya you like an angel and - goodbye
illian why save the flutes at the end and i
made a very difficult decision for myself,
you know, god forbid, to be faced with such a
choice that I faced honestly,
he excel or  pig more kitson guy photos
wet strong cancel many
describe your path as a way to overcome
yourself how did you manage to cope with
your fears and decide
to challenge
Lukashenko with raf was always present
that something seems to be in prison and will be
stronger also at this moment will be  your
children,
you stand every morning with the feeling
that those are scary, it's not
it means that you crossed the left, it means that you would have the
prescribed trump, you do something
because you can’t do it any other way,
because every person in Belarus now
does it this way for no one, it was easy for no one to
face the creatures,
Lukashenka’s security force ace plus is full of
miracles to
be in balance with us  you didn’t sew at night and
ripe
at night we realized that we couldn’t
hide there behind the backs of men quality there
on a solid style over our men
it means we will become their bride we with a
woman we will become these years we thought
that we would be beaten then
it seemed incredible
[  music]
here is this first simple
that we are ready we are with this beautiful
flowers we are peaceful people this is how
chic women another rocket women's
movement excited the whole world just the whole
world and women themselves then realized that it was
such a soft power she showed they
probably many did not expect  even from you,
at first I think that there was an instinctive action of
women and only then the
realization of that so much about
and active  fixing exactly kim dickens
awhile and cher
[music]
cipla on tikhonovskaya created by sergius tikhonovskiy
wave good they lukashenka
cleric buy you from running and proteins
in action in jail
taught where
that every strong man has
behind him
[music]
Lukashenka will have nights and a beautiful
currency we have a
tall angel-as vemrin carabela beach
unified
[music]
this question began to rise in general about the
woman leader when Lukashenka
began to say something the constitution did not  under a
woman something moments whom the housewife is a
cook
and in every possible way tries to ridicule me no, he
never offended me, but because that is,
that is, I, for a number of reasons, well, I was a
housewife for this match, the
truth of the data, if he wanted to mourn me
, he did not succeed, this insult
remained  him not to be shy
Tikhonovskaya once a peak for the Ministry of Emergency Situations Lopez on the
girls horican what island club
Serova vyr
you met with Angela Merkel in October,
why do you think it was so easy for you
to find a common language with her, this may
be due to the fact that she herself also grew up
in a dictatorship and therefore she
understands what this means  she had an
extremely benevolent video that in
fact her problem worries and so it’s
every time breaking Belarus, my emotions overwhelm me
and I wanted to show you now
Belarusians feel bad and hurt and that we need help we do
n’t feel the dress, it
is understood our pain she would like very much
to help us and she clearly clearly
affected this, she is so simple,
absolutely no arrogance,
well, so dear and the feeling of warmth
from a person, she in no way goes
against the fact that strong women are clear
what she is known for, yes, this is such a force of
arrogance and here she is so internal
and this  no need to talk skirts
to make it clear that she is a strong
leader of angela merkel so far the first
and only  a woman who managed to
become chancellor of Germany during the years of her
reign,
she paved the way for other women
politicians, while a feminist she does
not consider herself and you are a feminist, I would not
actually call myself
next to my husband uncle deeps is weak and I
like that he is strong and I  I would
gladly put all this burden on him,
I’m not stupid there, well, it’s different, I
want my
courageous man with me like this, and what
will you do when your husband is
released, it’s not a pity for you to leave everything,
you know  I don’t think that I will give up
everything because I got such a
tremendous experience, learned a lot
in what time and during this time and
felt my strength that I saw that
I could be useful to Belarusians when
we build our country, it is not necessary to
be president to be useful
but at the moment, looking
back at the amine, what happened in Belarus, the
topic is very close to me as a person, I’m ready
to be with the Belarusians, the stand is chipped  As soon as
necessary, we are leading to new elections, this is
our goal, and I don’t plan to participate in the new elections around the world
, but it’s not clear
what the situation will be, but suddenly I see you,
so I’ll have to be at the frontier and
broadcast everywhere here we are again and we believe
again and we trust  there to reduce dry,
I have already taken on such a
responsibility and and when I know
what is with me all of Belarus, then I will be able
to take on such responsibility in the
future do you want to mix in the mountains
lit one of us to this
Ivan iv concealer sedan words themselves
svetlana tikhonovskaya
and damper continent stands sing to the world
keeping in belarus
rabble for different clean write this
stating and all for babyzone with blood
clots edwards
[music]